nous ne sommes pas au Music alors s'il
vous plaît les applaudissements c'est
pour d'autres émissions merci
c'est une boîte aux lettres c'est génial
vous pouvez pas avoir votre avis
[Musique]
la politique d'union de la gauche reste
ce dont moi la seule issue autour du
programme commun attendez écoutez deux
choses l'une vous avez déjà reçu un
avertissement on essaie de tous les
syndicats de journalistes contre le fait
qu'on ne peut pas s'exprimer à Antenne 2
après communiquer que j'ai vu bon il y a
un communiqué des syndicats de
journalistes on y répondra quand il le
faudra monsieur ecoutez le cabash c'est
je crois une soirée suffisamment
sérieuse si vous pensez que ma place
n'est pas souhaitable puisque la droite
elle a gagné moi je laisse la place à la
droite je vais ailleurs on me demande
d'ailleurs je peux y aller
parce que c'est extrêmement désagréable
de discuter avec vous
[Musique]
ce que vous voulez de dire reflète un
peu ce que vous avez entendu sur la
lutte contre l'impérialisme progression
non parce que
vous ne parliez pas comme ça vous
arrivez pas comme ça vous mettre dans
votre petite tête que moi aussi j'ai un
cerveau et un cerveau qui est capable de
raisonner de réfléchir et de formuler
des propositions et des appréciations
[Applaudissements]
musicaux alors s'il vous plaît les
applaudissements c'est pour d'autres
émissions merci
ah non mais c'est vrai on va faire
toutes les missions avec des
applaudissements ou du sifflet
[Musique]
et on fait signe que Monsieur Chirac va
peut-être intervenir pour commenter ou
les résultats de la région parisienne
préparer ou monsieur Chirac vous êtes
avec nous en direct mais j'ai
l'impression qu'il n'entend pas monsieur
chiracle
en direct et un langage dès que tu es
hors caméra
[Musique]
c'est Noël le grec le président de la
Ligue A décréé à quelques jours que vous
allez plus présider l'Olympique de
Marseille le 9 c'est-à-dire après demain
c'est vrai déjà après demain non
et vous pourrez tenir même quand les
chiffres de l'audit dont on parle sur le
déficit de Marseille et alors pourquoi
il y a une boîte aux lettres en fait
c'est une boîte aux lettres c'est génial
j'ai l'impression d'être en face une
revue de presse
vous pouvez pas avoir votre avis
de donner des ordres
c'est une affirmation j'ai dit puisque
vous avez la chance je suis là vous me
demandez je vais vous dire quel est le
déficit comme je l'ai toujours dit
[Musique]
jusqu'à ce jour je l'ai été empêché de
rien et ce n'est pas qui de complexe ni
de sentiments de la possibilité
est-ce que vous savez combien de temps
il vous reste à vivre alors moi
naturellement comme je suis malade qui
heureusement n'est pas votre cas cela
peut être des accélérations mais je n'en
sais rien moi-même
je suis en situation de combat et quand
je livre un combat je me mets aussi dans
l'état d'esprit de celui qui gagnera
[Musique]